fans have been waiting a Whole Decade
for a new Grand Theft Auto game and
Miami Heat fans are especially freaking
out over the trailer now I don't play
video games but I can even appreciate
how cool this trailer is GTA 6 is based
in Miami Florida and the Heats CA Center
made a special appearance which is
making fans lose their mind they're
saying they hope they'll be able to
actually enter into the arena watch a
Heat game and even get to meet Jimmy
Butler or Tyler hero GTA 6 has some high
expectations after how well GTA 5 did
similar to the expectations Miami Heat
have this year but after last season's
performance from the Heat we know this
year will be big for them